hey there spider long time no see miss
me Felicia
[Music]
catch me if you can
hey everybody is Charlie this is going
to be my non-spoilery spider-man ps4
review I had a chance to check the game
out everything you've been hearing about
it is true everybody's going crazy about
it
it's totally warranted it is a worthy
successor to the Batman Arkham series
that's probably the closest comparison
that I could make in the way that it's
very open world you can interact with
everything
there's many missions and mini-games all
over the place that crossover with the
overarching storyline of this big turf
war between Wilson Fisk mr- in the
sinister six that make their presence
known later in the game so the early
part of the game just gets you used to
the mechanics it's pretty standard fare
for an Arkham game they get you to care
about the characters you spend a really
good part of the game especially early
on acting as Peter Parker and then the
spider-man
so the Peter Parker parts of the game
are just as important as the spider-man
parts they barely got there an infinity
war with spider-man swinging around
parkour while they were in that big
fight on Titan the earlier spider-man
movies spent more time with him swinging
around the big buildings of New York
City and they went above and beyond
sort of replicate that experience so
part of the fun of the game is you just
turning everything into your park or
playground the actual mechanics of you
swinging around the city are pretty
dynamic too it's a big part of the game
early on just learning how to control
him change direction mid-flight imagine
a version of the grappler mechanics and
Batman Arkham on steroids the characters
are great it reminded me a lot of Nathan
Drake's Uncharted series where you
really care about the history that these
characters have together and it sort of
takes you along as you evolve as a
character you've seen most of the early
ones from all the trailers Aunt May Mary
Jane who's actually a much bigger
character during this series that she's
been in any of the previous movies which
is kind of funny so if you feel like she
hasn't gotten her do she definitely gets
it during this everybody gets an arc
across the entire game the main game
itself I say is about a solid 20 hours
worth of gameplay if you don't spend a
lot of time going for side missions but
like you saw during spider-man
homecoming he webs backpacks up around
the city that's a big part of the game
too and you have to imagine that you
know in terms of open
old environment every borough of
Manhattan is represented the thing about
that though is when you go to a new
borough like say Hell's Kitchen there's
a tower game that you have to complete
to unlock the map before you can
actually see the mini-map and see where
you're going when you're traveling
around so you're flying blind when you
go into a new area until you unlock
everything as you've all seen you start
out in a classic suit then you
eventually make that white suit for you
you have to imagine this is an older
version of Peter Parker so you sort of
aged up through the game the whole thing
about the story is is that Peter Parker
is essentially the sole man on cleanup
duty with a couple of his friends
helping him out like Miles Morales and
Mary Jane Parker but I know you all have
questions about the sinister six
what's going on with Norman Osborn you
have to imagine that at the basic level
early on in the game before all this
stuff gets really really crazy later on
it really just starts out with Wilson
Fisk going down his gang fighting mr.
negatives gang for turf then it sort of
spirals into sinister six territory and
gets much bigger so you do have this
looming figure of Norman Osborn that's
trying to get rid of spider-man without
knowing that he's Peter Parker so there
is a bit of fun cat-and-mouse especially
because that character is at any of the
movies right now but is definitely a
solid way to spend your time waiting for
the venom movie to come out or if you're
excited about spider-man into the spider
verse which is coming out in December or
you just want to kill some time waiting
for Tom Hong to spoil something about
spider-man far from home or Avengers 4
which i think is a given at this point
they're still filming far from home
right now hey guys sorry the brothers
trusted ya thank the amazing support has
been incredible awesome stuff like this
go to my Instagram account go on the
link my bye up on the brothers trust
website and you'll get to come to say
hang out with me and it'll be amazing
and for the record I do all my own
stunts all of my own stunts I never ever
saw it's always me Tom Cruise does a
similar thing I'm the same I always
I know you have a lot of questions about
the suits there's a ton of awesome ones
they've only shown off a couple of them
there's at least 27 confirm ones right
now obviously those three DLC packs that
they announced at the beginning of this
they'll probably be more stuff that they
reveal and those too but the white
emblem suit that you see in all the
games marketing is just simply called
the advance suit you start out in the
classic suit then you make the advanced
suit then you can unlock some of the
other suits or they're part of
pre-orders you know standard game fare
but the other confirm ones so far are
the spider-man noir suit scarlet spiders
Ben Reilly suit spider armor mark 2 the
secret war suit Tom Hollands spider-man
homecoming suit the negative advance
suit probably gonna be DLC the electro
proof suit spider Punk the Kane Scarlet
Spider suit fear itself
big-time stealth suit spider armor mark
3 spider-man 2099 and everybody was
wondering about that the iron spider MCU
infinity war suit the velocity suit
spider armor mark for the ghost spider
suit spider-man 2099 Parker tech armor
the 90's animated series suit you guys
know I put that theme at the end of
pretty much all my Marvel videos now The
Last Stand suit Webb diapers which is
actually a thing from the comics where
he actually had to web himself up
because he didn't have any clothes Tom
Hollands original homemade suit from the
beginning of spider-man homecoming with
the hoodie then the more recent all-new
all-different stealth suit so like I
said that's only a list of about 27
there's gonna be way more than that
through DLC packs still have not heard
any confirmation about whether or not
they're going to incorporate venom into
it
people behind the game said different
things about that that seemed to
contradict each other so it's still a
bit of a mystery if they did incorporate
venom into it even though it's not there
at the start it would have to be some
sort of DLC later on so we'll see down
the road if they decide to incorporate
the symbiote suit but I think we're all
crossing our fingers for that but all in
all if you're a really big fan of
spider-man and you really like the way
Arkham games play this is probably gonna
be a really good time for you but like I
said you know starts out with about 20
hours of main storyline play the rest
spirals out with all the minigames and
all the side quests that you get to
complete so what I'm doing this week
because this is coming out is that all
my Marvel videos I'm doing giveaways for
the game all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
below congratulations to the winner from
my last big video trusting fawn 36
please email me on the back end of my
channel what's gonna happen is you may
have seen Henry Cavill was just cast as
Galt in The Witcher Netflix series so
more big video game related news
dropping this morning I'll do a video
for that next explaining what's going on
with that because I know there are a lot
of questions Kevin Feige just explained
a whole bunch of stuff about how captain
Marvel's powers are going to work on
what the scaling is for Avengers 4 click
here to learn all about that click here
for my new spider-man far from home
sinister six video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]